il ya des moments dans une vie
professionnelle qu'on n'oublie pas
j'étais formatrice d'enseignants le
sujet du jour était comment faire pour
aider tous les élèves à apprendre
j'animais la formation quand une jeune
enseignante la trentaine environ cinq
ans doute d'expérience assez nerveuse
m'interrompt et lâche
de toute façon moi je ne sers à rien
les élèves qui réussissent à apprendre
ils y arrivent très bien sans moi et
ceux qui n'y arrive pas je ne réussis
pas à les aider
ce n'était pas fini sa voisine plus
expérimentés qui avait l'air beaucoup
plus sûre d'elle se tournent vers elle
avec un petit sourire en coin et ajoute
tu sais moi ça fait 20 ans que c'est
comme ça ce que tu es enseignantes ont
exprimé s'appelle le sentiment
d'impuissance
je pense qu'elles ont dit tout ce que
tout le monde pense tout bas
le sentiment d'impuissance est tellement
sérieux que le c d e la mesure est dans
l'une de ces enquêtes internationales et
en france la situation est loin d'être
rose puisque une grande majorité
d'enseignants considèrent que leur
métier n'est pas valorisé par la société
chez moi en belgique francophone
le moral des enseignants n'est pas
meilleure le sentiment d'impuissance a
des conséquences graves
il produit de la souffrance au travail
il rend difficile de recruter des
enseignants ou de les garder dans la
carrière mais comment en est on arrivé
là
je crois que pour le comprendre il faut
revenir en arrière
souvenons nous nos systèmes scolaires
lorsqu'ils se sont développées au début
du 20e siècle avait pour objectif
d'enseigner au plus grand nombre
sur le modèle de la révolution
industrielle
on a standardisé un prof une heure une
classe de 25 à 30 élèves
une leçon
simple efficace la même chose pour tous
en gros le prof enseigne les élèves
apprennent ou pas pour certains d'entre
eux qui vont s'acharner à coups de prof
particulier quand papa et maman peuvent
payer ou qui vont quitter le système
scolaire est entré dans la vie active
mais petit à petit le malaise a grandi
parce que de plus en plus d'enfants ne
parvenait pas à prendre on s'est mis à
parler d'échec scolaire
quels termes terrible pourquoi mais tout
simplement parce qu'il y avait de plus
en plus d'élèves à l'école et qui
restait de plus longs de plus en plus
longtemps
les parents avaient bien compris que
sans diplôme pas de salut
on a appelé cela la massification de
l'enseignement mais alors face à cette
massification de l'enseignement et
l'augmentation de l'échec scolaire est
ce que les enseignants ont changé la
manière de faire leur métier
pas vraiment pas beaucoup aujourd'hui
encore l'enseignant a comme souci majeur
d'appliquer les programmes puisque c'est
ce qu'on lui demande
aujourd'hui encore l'enseignant enseigne
certains élèves apprennent beaucoup
n'apprennent pas alors lesquels
n'apprennent pas eh bien tout d'abord
ceux qui ne disposent pas des codes
sociaux et culturels de l'école les
enfants défavorisés également ceux qui
ne maîtrisent pas la langue de
l'enseignement par exemple les
primo-arrivants ceux qui ne maîtrisent
pas l'entrée dans l'écrit vous savez les
dyslexiques l'entrée dans le nombril
dyscalculiques l'entrée dans
l'orthographe les dix orthographique
ceux qui ne maîtrisent pas leur
attention des heures durant l'été bea a
même ceux
tu ne maîtrises pas la vitesse de leur
apprentissage les élève surdoué ou comme
on dit en belgique à haut potentiel les
élèves qui ne contrôle pas leur peur
maladive de l'échec les phobiques
scolaire les élèves qui ne maîtrisent
pas leur envie furieuse d'aller voir
dehors ou sur internet
le monde qui s'agite plutôt que de
rester à l'école tous ces élèves
démotivés
alors évidemment on ne peut pas laisser
tous sur le bord du chemin et de toute
façon la pression des parents sur
l'école est de plus en plus grande
aujourd'hui tout le monde est d'accord
pour dire que pour que ces élèves-là
apprennent il faut faire l' inverse de
la standardisation
il faut que les enseignants adaptent
leur apprentissage adaptent leurs
méthodes à chacun en gros ils doivent
changer de métier c'est bien de dire ça
mais comment les y aider alors moi
pendant longtemps j'ai cru comme
beaucoup d'autres d'ailleurs qu'il
fallait aider les enseignants à devenir
des praticiens réflexif jolis mots
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
eh bien les aider tout simplement à
mobiliser les connaissances
scientifiques récentes leur expertise
dans le quotidien de leur métier avec
cette idée là j'ai écrit des articles
des livres j'ai donné des conférences et
dans l'une d'elles je ne sais plus si
c'était sur la motivation la spirale de
l'échec ou l'estiment de soi un
enseignant très fâché lève la main et
dit ok ok c'est très bien là tout ça
mais moi tout seul dans ma classe avec
mes élèves je fais comment quand vous
êtes face à une salle pleine de profs
il faut trouver quelque chose à répondre
alors je les regardais j'ai dit mais ça
moi je ne sais pas c'est vous le
professionnel c'est vous qui devez
construire les réponses un peu court
mais j'ai pris au sérieux ce que m'a dit
cet enseignant et d'autres d'ailleurs
et j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir mettre
les mains dans le cambouis comme
conseiller de la ministre de
l'enseignement en belgique francophone
alors quel était le problème chez nous
en belgique pour personnaliser les
apprentissages
on utilise une stratégie pédagogique un
peu particulière le redoublement
ah oui quand on élève la prend pas au
même rythme que les autres
c'est simple il recommence son année
vous utilisez ça aussi en france mais
nous sommes les champions du monde en
terminale 60 % de nos élèves ont au
moins une année de retard 30% deux
années de retard et on utilise le
redoublement dès la grande section
maternelle
d'abord c'est inefficace
en plus ça coûte extrêmement cher mais
surtout sa mine il envie d'apprendre de
très nombreux élèves
donc évidemment la ministre souhaitait
qu'on s'attaque sérieusement au problème
dans ces cas là dans la plupart des cas
on met en place un projet pilote nous
avons donc demandé à une équipe de
chercheurs de travailler très
étroitement avec dix écoles pour les
aider à utiliser des outils pédagogiques
des jeux de lecture de calcul d'écriture
afin de permettre aux enseignants de
porter un autre regard sur leurs élèves
d'identifier leurs forces leurs
compétences plutôt que de se centrer sur
leurs lacunes leurs faiblesses ça a
plutôt bien marché mais nous avons
calculé que si vous voulez toucher tous
les enseignants de belgique francophone
ils allaient nous falloir un siècle et
je n'ose pas vous dire combien de
millions d'euros il nous fallait
absolument trouver une autre démarche
nous avons alors proposé de construire
une communauté de pratiques que nous
avons appelé la communauté décollage les
écoles étaient libres de s'y inscrire
librement pourquoi faire pour y trouver
des outils pédagogiques ces jeux dont je
vous ai parlé mais surtout
pour se les approprier lors de
formations lors de tende échanges entre
enseignants mais également avec la
direction de l'école les psychologues
scolaires
d'autres enseignants afin de construire
collectivement des réponses concrètes au
quotidien dans leur classe mais la plus
grande innovation de la communauté
décollage à mes yeux c'est que nous
avons également mobilisés la deuxième
ligne
les conseillers pédagogiques des
formateurs d'enseignants
les inspecteurs les services de
l'administration même l'équipe du
cabinet nous avons travaillé tous les
mois afin d'identifier les besoins
concrets des acteurs de première ligne
d'évaluer ce qui marche et ce qui ne
marchait pas d'identifier les
innovations qu'ils avaient mise en place
de développer un discours commun alors
vous allez me dire c'est bien une
communauté de pratique ça a l'air
intéressant mais est ce que ça marche at
on des chiffres oui trois ans plus tard
les statistiques du ministère montrent
que le redoublement en grande section de
maternelle a diminué de moitié et qu'il
a tendance à diminuer significativement
dans l'ensemble des années de
l'enseignement élémentaire mais moi il
ya un autre chiffre que je préfère on
espérait une centaine d'écoles dans la
communauté de décollage on en a eu trois
cent trois fois plus une sur six et la
moitié des centres psycho médico sociaux
qui travaillent avec les écoles et qui
ont un rôle fort important dans les
décisions de redoublement nous avons
également eu de beaux succès d estime
même un syndicat enseignant à
plébisciter la démarche décollage dans
sa revue mensuelle et l' ocde
à sélectionner la communauté décollage
avec quatre autres réformes pédagogiques
pour la faire analyser en profondeur par
des experts afin d'inspirer d'autres
systèmes scolaires
moi ce que j'ai retenu de plus important
de cette expérience avec la communauté
décollage j'ai envie de vous le faire
partager ce soir je veux prendre très au
sérieux ce sentiment d'impuissance des
acteurs de première ligne pour cela je
suis convaincu qu'il faut investir dans
cette deuxième ligne une deuxième ligne
solide que j'appelle les intermédiaires
en éducation
ce sont des agents de changement
extraordinaire la communauté des
collages me l'a montré
mais ils sont trop peu nombreux trop mal
formés ils n'ont pas suffisamment de
temps pour travailler avec les
enseignants ils doivent développer des
méthodologies nouvelles efficaces
l'avantagé c'est que cette deuxième
ligne ne coûte pas très cher et qu'elle
a des effets démultiplicateurs et oui
quand vous touchez un enseignant vous
espérer toucher 25 à 30 élèves
quand vous touchez un formateur
d'enseignants ou un conseiller
pédagogique vous en toucher 2500 3000
mais surtout vous installer de manière
durable des pratiques professionnelles
qui soutiennent ces acteurs de première
ligne avec nos enfants